[Music]
man
you got yourself
we're here
working on John Wick chapter four And So
It Begins
John mcswag cars and weapons
[Music]
with chapter four
we took it to another level
foreign
[Music]
is out
John Wick movies they're known for Keanu
Reeves doing the stunts it's been about
12 weeks of trim it's new levels of
action you know let's have Moon shots
which was challenging
Keanu attitude and the talent whether
it's handling a gun how it reloads it's
compelling to see him do it
you armed
John Wick action asks just a little bit
more and you see the effort and the
commitment from the team Ian McShane is
back with Lawrence Fishburne and Lance
Reddick and then we have Donnie yang
Bill Skarsgard hiroyuki sonoda Clancy
Brown Shamir Anderson
incredible Natalia antenna Scott Adkins
fighting Kiana Reeves
and also we have Arena saranyama
we make it look easy but it's not
for chapter four we wanted to bring the
muscle cars back we really wanted to do
something different we're gonna have the
sequence
around the Arctic triangle
we tore all the doors off and lost the
windshield you're gonna do a reverse 180
and you got to shoot a gun and you gotta
reload he actually started getting too
good in the car
we're smashing people hitting people
it's just amazing we've shot some stuff
that pushes John Wick to the Limit
gone too far
this hit
goes out to you Mr Wick
42 regular wasn't it yeah
and so it begins
challenging to single combat if you win
you'll have your freedom
amen
it flutty
the only way John Wick will ever have
freedom
and peace
[Music]
yeah not really
foreign
[Music]